celebrate Christmas we tried to book
Santa but he's a Book Soup doing a
signing for his new coffee table book at
tasteful elf nudes luckily we were able
to get his Austrian counterpart he
appears at homes and hobbles all over
Europe and his biopic Krampus has 65
percent on Rotten Tomatoes all the way
from the Teutonic forests of middle
Europe Krampus is here
hey Chris your audience probably doesn't
recognize me because Americans aren't
aware of anybody's traditions but their
own yeah what an authentic Austrian
accent you have so why are you here
forty sixteen no Chris better accent
almost twenty seventeen Santa Claus is
on the way out too old too jolly it
makes you wonder what is he hiding he's
crooked crooked Santa all right so
you're saying that Santa Claus is
corrupt
yes he's too nice he rewards children
for being good and that's not what real
Americans just voted for they voted for
kids to be punished punished with
bundles of sticks
that's where I come in every year I go
around to people's homes and thrash kids
with sticks that's my thing isn't that
what Christmas is all about Christmas
the thrashing of children with bundles
of sticks well I don't I don't know
comedians is a good question what is
Christmas all about mallanna the
fashioning of children with bundles of
sticks okay all right that combination
Nick what is Christmas about Christmas
is about my uncle rod taking too many
clothes up creepy pictures of my wife
all right I'm not being judgey but you
seem to be particularly obsessed with
this idea of thrashing children with
bundles of sticks why uh it's just so
practical think of the money you'll save
on toys you buy a Hachem all right 60 70
bucks whatever they cost I don't know I
don't go to toy stores I'm a grown man
I send my assistant Michelle to the toy
store for me okay
then you give the toy to the kid and
they start screaming because of your
horns and sold fur breath wouldn't it
just be cheaper to buy one bundle twigs
that you can use to thrash them well I
mean I guess I guess if you lay it out
that way then yeah thank you all right
I mean it seems like you're spending a
lot of time collecting small sticks when
you can really just grab one big stick
[Applause]
so obsessed with sticks you cannot go
around hitting children wrong what just
it's wrong no you can't song no I'm
right you can't just go around swatting
kids with sticks I mean I'm Billy hi
billy whack what did we do these fake
invisible kids in front of you there has
to be a better way comedians what's a
better modern punishment for a child
Aparna giving them gluten all right boys
you you take away their Pokemon and then
you tell them that the divorce is their
fault okay good yeah listen that's a lie
parents it and I turned out fine so what
is your point with all this Krampus
my point is Santa Claus is a what
you heard me google it ooh America needs
to upgrade this year to a new Christmas
guy me Krampus the alt Santa
I'm going to make I'm going to make
Christmas trade again I can tell you
that I'm going to make Christmas great
again rather than beating people with
wood there's got to be a better way to
make Christmas great again so how do we
do that Varna putting putting the Christ
back in Jesus place this country is
[Applause]
whatever if you really want to their
children fresh with sticks on Christmas
not all children Chris just most
children my elves will start a database
to keep track of all the naughty kids
and make sure they're all rounded up and
sent to camp hey you hey no you know let
me finish
ok send them to summer camp
oh ok all right that's there we go well
they will be sorted according to
religion and sexual orientation all
right that's it we're done what we're
done with you please thank you Krampus